what makes a real tricky
if you don't love all star trek does
that mean you're not a trekkie
welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
foreign
so i'm doing this bit of a rant
sorry
because of the comment you just saw i
just added the photo at the start there
but basically this guy has put a comment
on um a side of star trek group saying
that the reasons why we got strange new
worlds is because of disco seasons one
and two i assume it means season two
really and if you loved discovery season
one and two you're the reason why this
series got made
if you moaned about stark uh discovery
seasons one and two again i think he
means season two really because that's
the bit with pike in
and then
but i've then enjoyed strange new worlds
then you're a charlatan
you're not really a trekkie and how dare
you call yourself one
i
replied politely calling him a load of
rubbish and saying there's a load of
nonsense
i complain about star trek discovery
since one or two and i complain about
picard because i'm a trekkie
because i love star trek that's the
whole reason why i get so annoyed when
it's not good enough
jj abrams star trek
very good movies i actually enjoy them
as films they're not particularly tricky
though they're not really star trek
anything that pees all over canon annoys
me i don't like it
anything that just doesn't make sense
annoys me and i don't like it so yeah i
complain about star trek but i complain
about star trek because i'm a trekkie
and because i love star trek i want it
to be better i hire i hold it to a
higher standard than other sci-fi
i expect more from what basically is the
king of sci-fi as far as i'm concerned
it's the pinnacle what all of the sci-fi
should aim to become or to at least
compare itself to
i complain because i love it
anybody that blindly just loves anything
with star trek and doesn't moan and then
goes on other stars or you're toxic
you're a toxic fan yeah
needs to go and grow up basically
because that's not how real life works
that's not how anything really works
i'm not blindly going to love star trek
just because it says star trek at the
start i am however going to complain
about it when it's not good enough
now strange new worlds the first episode
was brilliant i really enjoyed it
i really enjoyed the first episode of
picard i've done a video about it i told
you how much i loved it
hopefully strange new worlds will
fulfill all of the hopes that we have
for it
and misses a lot of the fears that i
have for it
but
anybody dares say to me that i am not a
trekkie because i complain about
anything that happens in star trek needs
to grow up
because i moan because i care because
i'm a true fan and because i'm not a
blinded
so sorry about this short ranty video
but i had to get it off my chest i hope
you don't mind
please get in the comments tell me what
you think do you think we should just
shut up and stop moaning because if we
moan too much we might get star trek
cancelled and i have to be fair none of
us want that
or
am i right
do we hold star trek to a higher
standard because we're trekkies and
because we love it and it should be
better tell me what you think and if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit the bell notification it
really helps us out also you can become
a fully fledged side tracker consider
hitting the join button
have a lovely day it's sunny out here in
the uk look at that lovely
so please guys stay safe i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you